[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 27 septembre
bienvenue dans le journal de tv 78 lé
titre de cette édition
elle vient de se clôturer avec les
journées européennes du patrimoine la
saison touristique estivale a livré ses
verdicts dans le département
quel bilan tirer en cette journée
mondiale du tourisme nous recevons
joséphine coleman bergé vice présidente
du conseil départemental des yvelines en
charge notamment du tourisme
après l'obtention des jo ou 2024 à la
france également en lice pour accueillir
l'exposition universelle 2025 sur le
plateau de saclay le dossier de
candidature est remis demain on en parle
avec françois durovray président du
conseil départemental de l'essonne qui
porte ce projet enfin tensions autour du
café de la plage à maurepas certains ne
voient pas d'un bon oeil la nouvelle
politique de la ville concernant la
salle de spectacle le conseil municipal
et était ainsi perturbé hier soir les
détails dans ce journal
ils étaient plus d'une centaine réunis
la nuit dernière devant l'abattoir
guillou d'anguilla rende ou dans des
militants ont répondu à l'appel lancé
par l'association 269 life est
libération animale volonté d'attirer
l'attention du public sur les conditions
d'abattage des animaux une nuit debout
mondial organisé sur 65 sites en
belgique au canada et même en australie
sur ces images vous voyez l'opération
menée dans les yvelines
une veillée hommage aux victimes d'une
société d'une institution spéciste ce
sont les mots d'une militante de
l'association ont les couteaux micro de
camille lambert et nicolas kirillovitch
une association antispécistes c'est à
dire qu'on est pour la libération de
tous les animaux tous les êtres vivants
et contre leur exploitation
ce soir donc du coup c'est vraiment une
nuit spéciale c'est vraiment un
événement qui est partout partout dans
le monde dans plusieurs villes de france
et c'est vraiment un recueillement pour
tous les animaux des abattoirs je vous
en parlais dans les titres invités de ce
journal joséphine coleman ce berger
bonsoir l'ancien vous êtes vice
présidente du conseil à départementale
des yvelines en charge notamment du
tourisme on va parler justement avec
vous
du bilan touristique pour la saison
d'été dans le département est il bon ou
pas mais avant une actualité qu'on ne
peut éluder c'est la présidence de saint
quentin en yvelines élu sénateur michel
laugier va quitter tout prochainement
son poste de président de
l'agglomération
vous êtes-vous première vice présidente
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
question simple et directe êtes-vous
candidate pour succéder à michel laugier
je pensais être venu pour le tourisme
pendant un instant une petite question
pour débuter cet entretien je pense que
les enfants répètent les informations
vont être beaucoup plus clair en fin de
semaine puisque une demande a été faite
de façon collégiale par par les élus de
de faire une demande de candidature et
les candidatures seront closes à la fin
de la semaine donc à ce moment là vous
aurez certainement une réponse plus
claire de la part des personnes qui se
seront engagés dans cette possibilité
donc d'abord way des discussions au sein
de la majorité et ses actes et ses
soeurs exactement donc merci d'accepter
cette réponse
on suivra bien sûr cette actualité alors
passons à notre deuxième thématique
c'est aujourd'hui la journée mondiale du
tourisme et même si le ton n'a pas été
trop clément au mois de septembre l'été
a bel et bien pris fin il ya seulement
six jours la saison est toujours une
période très importante pour le secteur
du tourisme joséphine coleman bergé elle
et il l'était at il été globalement bon
pour le département des yvelines sur le
secteur du tourisme
bah écoutes je pourrais dire oui plutôt
favorable il y a eu des enquêtes qui ont
été faites un haut niveau d hôtellerie
au niveau de l'hôtellerie au niveau des
gîtes et puis au niveau des sites
également touristiques et on s'est rendu
compte que les résultats sont bien
supérieurs à ceux de l'année dernière
donc on a en a je dirais des retours sur
47 % de demandes que nous employons nous
n'avons plus faire au niveau de nos
partenaires et bien avoir des retours
plutôt positif dans différents domaines
avec des explications et c'est clair on
va parler de ces différents domaines
alors il ya les journées européennes du
patrimoine aussi qu'ils ont clôturé on
va dire officiellement cette saison
dt l'opération at elle fonctionné dans
les élites même si on est très proche
encore de cet événement est ce qu'il ya
eu des retours globalement bons aussi
sur ces journées européennes
oui je crois que c'est véritablement une
manifestation qui porte non seulement
ses fruits mais qui est attendu par la
population avec ses ouvertures
d'équipements et de sites qui sont en
fait que le général assez fermé et on a
on a des retours très positifs qui
accompagne justement ce tourisme qui est
plutôt un tourisme local un tourisme
hillbilly noir voire ile de france et
c'est quelque chose que l'on ressent
comme étant je dirais une vraie
implication non seulement de nos
professionnels mais aussi de tout tout
toutes les actions qui sont faites au
niveau de la culture par les
collectivités elles mêmes alors
justement pour 47% des professionnels du
tourisme que vous avez interrogé vous
avez mené une enquête sur le sujet 47%
de ses professionnels jugent la saison
bonne 39 % en moyenne
après un été 2016 disons le 2016 très
négatif à vous parler du temps qui
imaginent
oui c'est vrai que le temps n'a pas été
très favorable malgré tout on a eu un
retour alors un retour de d'un tourisme
international
il faut le dire ils avaient tendance à
sion et la clientèle étrangère est
tendance iphone alors fuir c'est un mot
peut-être un peu fort mais en tout cas
une inquiétude certes une inquiétude on
se rend compte que il ya une confiance
qui est fait vis-à-vis des
professionnels du tourisme et aussi je
dirais de tout ce qui est encadrement au
niveau de la sécurité par rapport à ça
d'ici cité à ces lieux donc c'est plutôt
bon signe
on a vraiment des signes très positifs
non seulement comme je le disais tout à
l'heure sur des personnes qui viennent
d'ile-de-france sur des sites reconnus
plutôt sur la localité proche
et puis aussi sur tout un tas un secteur
international on a pu constater une
véritable mot c'est un exemple de cette
reprise justement côté city est le
château de versailles un qu'on connaît
bien sûr là la vitrine de ce département
des yvelines alors il ya une
augmentation moyenne de 13% du nombre de
visiteurs cet été sur le château de
versailles et ce malgré une météo en
juillet qui était on va dire oui assez
mauvaise moyenne moyenne
moyenne et on a une augmentation
importante sur le château de versailles
vous savez que nous avons entre 7
millions 5 et 8 millions de visiteurs
sur le château de versailles
en règle générale le but aussi il faut
dire c'est nous souhaiterions que les
touristes puissent aussi s'installer
davantage sur le département des
yvelines
parce que bien sûr c'est un lieu de
passage absolument majestueux et super
mai puis une représentation de la france
qui est quand même à implanter mais le
but aussi du travail du département par
rapport au tourisme c'est de pouvoir
maintenir cette manne touristique sur
les sites des yvelines où nous avons une
richesse extraordinaire à la fois dans
la ruralité dans les cités dans les
gîtes et dans les hôtels avait passé
deux nuits dans les hôtels lillois
plutôt que sur un hôtel parisien
c'est un objectif je sais que les
offices de tourisme font un travail
remarquable
justement pour essayer de d'accompagner
tout cela et le département aussi fait
un travail très fort ne serait ce que
pour valoriser tous nos sites on a mais
je pense qu'on aura peut-être le loisir
juste d'en échanger sur deux mots on a
aujourd'hui tout un plan sur le tourisme
qui a été fait en collaboration étroite
avec le 92 parce que vous le savez nous
à nous sommes actuellement dans une
approche de fusion pour un jour 8 bien
sûr les du 92 et le tourisme est un des
projets déjà phare de cohésion et de
fusion entre les deux départements et
notre objectif bien sûr c'est d'orienter
le tourisme sur huit axes que nous avons
déjà déterminé alors les hôteliers
également iv noah juge cette saison
plutôt bonne une petite petite ombre au
tableau peut-être de cet été touristique
c'est les locations saisonnières là
encore un été morose on a du mal et
propriétaires ne font pas forcément très
satisfait oui c'est à dire que
c'est pas l'embellie qui l'aurait
souhaité en même temps on se rend compte
que il ya aussi un gros effort de la
part de ces professionnels nous avons
nous les avons réunis autour d'ateliers
travail pour véritablement ressentir ce
qu'ils attendaient du département est ce
que nous pouvions aussi nous faire pour
eux et on s'est rendu compte qu'il y a
une force extraordinaire d'imagination
et d'amélioration de cet accueil à la
population tente au niveau des
manifestations privées comme des
mariages mais aussi sur tout ce qui est
professionnel avec des séminaires et ça
on se rend compte qu'il ya une vraie
professionnalisation de tous ces lieux
là qui sont véritablement extraordinaire
et qu'on voudrait valoriser encore plus
un dernier mot peut-être sur les
perspectives qu'elles sont ls que la
reprise va se poursuivre les
professionnels nous disent qu'ils sont
véritablement une remontée et nous on le
sent également et je pense que ce qu'on
met en place actuellement au niveau
départemental puisque pour nous le
tourisme est avant tout un développement
économique faut pas l'oublier et
tourisme et par un gadget c'est
véritablement quelque chose sur lesquels
on peut s'appuyer au niveau de hauts
niveaux de ne serait-ce que sur l'île de
france on a quand même 47 millions de
tourisme
chaque année c'est pas rien c'est 10 %
du pib de l'île de france donc tout cela
est quelque chose qu'il faut regarder
avec beaucoup d'intérêt par rapport au
développement économique et l'emploi
merci à joséphine comme jacques berger
d'abord être avec nous à vice président
du conseil départemental des yvelines en
charge notamment du tourisme et pour
plus d'infos sur les sites les hôtels
des yvelines vous pouvez vous rendre sur
le site internet qui s'affiche en bas de
l'écran embellie côté et tourisme ce
n'est pas le cas pour le chômage dans le
département augmentation de 2,2 pour
cent au mois d'août pour la catégorie ya
osseux plus forte qu'au niveau national
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi sans
aucune activité s'établissait fin août à
près de 66 1900 personnes sur un an là
encore c'est une progression + 1 % pour
cette catégorie dans les yvelines
c'est l'une des conséquences des
attentats qui ont frappé la france le
département des yvelines va installer
quatre mille caméras dans les 116
collèges du territoire et les casernes
de pompiers expérimentation sur 12 sites
pilote le dispositif totalement
opérationnel d'ici
2019 ces appareils seront reliés à un
poste central avec sur place au moins
six agents et les précisions de karl
olive vice président du conseil
départemental propos recueillis par
nicolas kirillovitch et wilfrid richy
investissement de 13 millions dans les
116 collèges du département dans les
casernes de pompiers notamment tout
simplement pour créer une plate forme
mutualisée d' images de vidéo protection
dans un espèce de maillage de logiciels
robotisée qui fait que des cures un
moule vaut un mouvement de foule dans
tous ces endroits se sera directement
opérationnels dans ce centre de
supervision urbain efficacité réactivité
aujourd'hui dans le pays en état
d'urgence ce qui est nécessaire
évidemment c'est la réactivité par
rapport à des incidents de plus ou moins
grande importance
atmosphère tendue du côté de maurepas au
café de la plage beaucoup de personnes
ne digère pas la nouvelle politique de
la ville concernant la salle de
spectacle plus de têtes d'affiché une
grande place donnée à la scène locale
stratégie redouté ainsi le conseil
municipal a été hier soir perturber le
point avec mélanie poquet et aurélie
ronces un concert improvisé lors du
conseil municipal de maurepas l'image
n'est pas banal plus d'une centaine de
personnes s'étaient déplacées pour
montrer leur mécontentement contre la
nouvelle orientation culturelle du café
de la plage leurs craintes
la fermeture progressive du lieu j'ai
commencé là-bas en tant que bénévole et
maintenant je suis technicienne lumière
et c'est aussi grâce au café de la plage
que je fais ce métier j'ai pas envie que
ce genre de lieux fermés
pour moi faut que ça continue pour la
municipalité pas de fermeture du café de
la plage mais en raison d'une baisse des
dotations de l'état
la programmation a été réorganisé le
lieu est désormais dédié aux expositions
aux actions culturelles et à la
promotion des artistes locaux me paraît
important en tout cas de faire
comprendre que le café de la plage et
bien sûr utilisé entre autres par le
cobalt pour réunir les groupes qui le
souhaitent puissent toutes les musiques
de groupes locaux
vous pensez bien que
nous avons besoin comme dans toutes les
structures déficiences de mutualisation
et c'est ce que nous avons voulu faire
un message qui n'a pas vraiment réussi à
convaincre les manifestants
le fermer pendant quatre mois le
réouvrir pendant une date leur fermer
pendant quatre mois et le réouvrir
pendant une date à partir du moment où
il ya plus d'équipés en place parce que
c'est le cas et à partir du moment où ça
ouvre aussi peu c'est à dire trois fois
basses et fermé
si on fait une saison culture avait que
trois dates dans l'année je sais pas
trop ce que ça veut dire mais l'année
prochaine on sait très bien que ça veut
dire ah bah n'y avait pas assez de
personnes donc du coup ils vont du coup
ils vont ils vont se dire bon ben on va
le faire mais comme ça c'est réglé
face à cette action
la municipalité a proposé aux
manifestants de solliciter un rendez
vous individuel
elle sera fixée dans un peu plus d'un an
la france est candidate à l'organisation
de l'exposition universelle 2025
elle a copié rendu officiellement demain
au bureau international des expositions
face au japon à la russie à
l'azerbaïdjan la france donc qui prévoit
de construire son village global lieu
central de l'événement sur le territoire
de paris saclay agglomérations voisines
de saint quentin en yvelines bonsoir
françois durovray président du conseil
départemental de l'essonne vous porter
cette candidature
alors avant de parler des éventuels
travaux et bénéfices que pourrait
engendrer l'expo petite réaction par
rapport à cette phrase la métropole du
grand paris ne sert à rien
propos de valérie pécresse dans les
colonnes du parisien ce matin à la
présidente ait l'air de la région
répondait à une question sur un projet
d' emmanuel macron le président est de
la république envisagerait de supprimer
les départements de la petite couronne
au profit de la métropole du grand paris
êtes vous d'accord avec valérie pécresse
et est du coup est-ce que c'est déjà un
risque pour l'organisation de l'expo
universelle
je répondrai que la métropole c'est la
région à l'évidence nous vivons tous sur
un territoire qui est celui d'île de
france et ou sur lesquels les questions
de transport les questions de logement
les questions d'aménagement du
territoire sont extrêmement liés et
d'ailleurs avec mes collègues présidents
de départements de gauche comme de
droite nous allons
prendre des initiatives pour justement
parler de cet avenir institutionnel et
faire en sorte que ce soit plus simple
demain alors revenons à l'exposition
universelle vous serez vendredi aux
côtés de jean christophe fromantin pour
présenter ce dossier de la candidature
expo france a donc à lui à l'exposition
universelle de vienne 25
quelles sont les chances de paris-saclay
de l'exposition universelle
quelles sont les chances pour la france
d'organiser cet événement et ses chances
elles sont immenses parce que d'abord la
france n'a pas organisé l'exposition
universelle depuis très longtemps que
d'autre part nous avons des concurrents
qui sont certes sérieux mais qui ont des
projets qui sans doute sont moins humain
que le projet de la candidature
française ce projet d'accord française
c'est la connaissance à partager la
planète à protéger c'est une ouverture
de la france au reste du monde et c'est
vrai que le territoire de paris saclay a
été retenu sans doute parce qu'il
correspond le mieux à cette identité à
cette image que la france veut donner au
reste du monde et que dans nos dossiers
de candidature on y reviendra peut-être
on a quelques atouts à faire valoir et
donc recevoir pendant l'exposition
universelle sur le territoire ça
pourrait être une chance incroyable il
ya une étude du cabinet deloitte qui a
chiffré les retombées de cette expo
universelle ça pourrait être cent
soixante mille emplois à créer 23
milliards d'euros de retombées
économiques
il faut bien se rendre compte que
l'exposition universelle à la différence
des jeux olympiques les d'ailleurs nous
sommes très heureux qu'ils aient des
jeux olympiques et c'est d'ailleurs un
atout pour la candidature d'exposition
universelle parce que ça témoigne de la
capacité de la france à organiser des
grands événements internationaux à
croyait recevoir et l'ex-président au
contraire c'est plutôt un atout et
d'autres pays l'espagne le brésil ont
réussi à avoir organisé de manière
concomitante des événements de grande
ampleur mais c'est vrai que l'exposition
universelle à la différence des jeux
olympiques c'est 35 millions de
visiteurs sur une durée de six mois et
donc des retombées économiques qui sont
considérables et un événement qui est
portée par l'investissement privé
alors si la france est retenue pour
organiser cette expo universelle à quoi
ressemblerait le site sur paris saclay
c'est trop tôt pour le dire est ce qu'on
a indiqué dans la candidature c'est que
nous réservions un espace de 110
hectares
l'image qu'on voit à l'image taper un
espace de 110 hectares pour accueillir
les pavillons de chacun des pv et
d'ailleurs dans notre candidature nous
avons proposé aux pays de pouvoir rester
sur le territoire de paris saclay après
l'exposition universelle c'était d'avoir
un héritage et de créer la cité
internationale du 21e siècle pour que
ces pays puissent accueillir à paris
saclay leurs étudiants ou leur
entreprise qui ont vocation à foisonner
avec le territoire et quand je dis le
territoire ces sacs les côtes et les
sols mais évidemment que telltale
vivoter yvelines et est donc qu au delà
de ces 110 ha bah ya des images qui sont
diffusées comme celles que vous avez
montré à l'écran mais qui feront l'objet
si la france est retenue d'un concours
international et donc il y aura sans
doute une vision différente de celle
qu'on donne aujourd'hui mais du coup
avec cette candidature
quid aussi la ligne 18 reliant
l'aéroport d'orly à versailles en
passant par le plateau de saclay il faut
aller plus vite sur le dossier il faut
que cette ligne arrive avant l'expo
universelle à belledune
il est prévu lui est prévu avant
l'exposition universelle l'ouverture de
la ligne 18 jusqu'à saclay way est
prévue pour 2025 tronçon jusqu'à
verneuil tiens nous rêvions l'ordination
vercel la question évidemment c'est la
prolongation que nous souhaitons de
cette ligne 18 au delà de saclay mais je
crois que le gouvernement justement
aujourd'hui en train de réfléchir et de
positionner les différents
investissements un dernier mot peut-être
sur le calendrier alors le département
de l'essonne avec l'agglomération
paris-saclay s'est engagé à apporter une
enveloppe cessa de 35 à 60 7 millions
d'euros pour l'organisation en fait
l'exposition universelle je vous
l'indiqué c'est un avis m'emporter par
le cul les 3 milliards 500 millions
d'euros simplement le privé c'est
légitime a besoin de l'assurance que les
collectivités seront à l'heure sur les
infrastructures ça concerne l'état avec
la ligne 18 ça concerne les
collectivités locales avec des
investissements qui sont de toute façon
prévu comme la création d'un
téléphérique entre le rer b et le
plateau de saclay ou une couverture
partielle de la 118 qui sera utile à
l'exposition universelle mais qui sera
utile aussi aux territoires
après l'exposition universelle est le
dossier de candidature est remis et je
le rappelle demain
merci françois durovray d'avoir été avec
nous président du conseil départemental
de l'essonne vous porter cette
candidature de la france pour
l'exposition universelle 2025
et pour plus d'infos sur cette
candidature et via le site internet
d'expo france 2025 qui s'affiche pour
nos téléspectateurs
c'est notre fil rouge de la semaine on
continue notre dossier sur le logement
étudiant ce soir rencontre avec une
jeune lilloise qui a monté son dossier
en dernière minute pour obtenir une
chambre elle a dû passer plusieurs jours
à l'hôtel avant de se voir accorder une
place à elancourt reportage de michael
et me doro nicolas landry et patrick
jacques de dixmude des idées nouvelles
j'ai appelé le crous effectivement ils
vont te faire l'attribution du logement
ce sera il encore fin du calvaire pour
audrey lecouffe cette jeune étudiante en
master 2 originaire de lille va enfin
pouvoir poser ses valises et ses livres
dans la résidence rené cassin
d'elancourt qu'elle était en recherche
active d'un logement étudiant depuis fin
août à quelques jours de la reprise des
cours
audrey a dû attendre deux semaines avant
d'avoir deux propositions pendant quinze
jours c'était c'était moi ma voiture et
mon sac quoi honnêtement c'était jeu
réservé à la dernière minute un hôtel à
droite à gauche
je regarde à combien de kilomètres il
est de la fac je regarde où est ce que
je vais pouvoir me garer faire ceci cela
une recherche de dernière minute risqué
selon le responsable du service logement
il est conseillé de monter son dossier
avant les vacances estivales
et lorsque la recherche de logement
commence vers fin routes au mois de
septembre
la plupart des logements sont attribués
les offres il ya très peu d'offres est
généralement les offres qui restent sont
du plus élevé pour le crous du site
versailles saint quentin qui gère neuf
résidences universitaires et 1200
logements entre saint cloud il encourt
la procédure a été respectée
le risque zéro n'existe pas cependant on
a un taux de satisfaction que très élevé
et là en l'occurrence n'y a pas eu
dysfonctionnement il ya une demande
tardive
on était particulièrement réactif c'est
qu'elle était la procédure
elles s'étaient d'abord adressés à nos
partenaires de l'université versailles
saint quentin qui nous ont transmis le
dossier pour plus de réactivité
la directrice des résidences
universitaires est allée elle-même
portel dossier aux services centraux
le 14 septembre dréan ménages enfin dans
son nouvel appartement à elancourt un
studio de 20 m² loués 377 euros sans
avoir déduit les aides personnalisées au
logement c'est les aléas en fait c'est
malheureusement si on n'est pas prêt à
vivre ça à notre âge on n'est pas prêt à
vivre choses par la suite quoi ça va
plus perturbée au niveau du budget ça
c'est sûr heureusement mes parents sont
là d'ailleurs même si j'ai souvent eu
des jobs pour compenser quoi audrey va
maintenant se concentrer sur ses études
elle devrait rester dans son logement
étudiant à elancourt jusqu'au mois de
janvier et la fin de son diplôme
mercredi c'est bien sûr le jour des
sorties au cinéma ce film arrivera dans
les salles le 11 octobre coexistaient de
fabrice éboué l'histoire de la création
d'un groupe de musique composé d'un
prêtre d'un rabbin et d'un imam à une
avant-première du film était proposé à
l'ugc ciné-cité skywest patrick jacques
de dixmude et mélanie poker ont
rencontré fabrice éboué si dans moins de
six mois monsieur musique n'a pas rempli
le lapi avec un nouvel art is et cédera
sa place de directeur pour son troisième
film fabrice éboué nicolas un producteur
un peu à la ramasse en manque de
résultats il nota groupe avec un prêtre
un rabbin un imam la certaine
ressemblance avec le trio de prêtres
chanteurs dette assumée
mais pourquoi on fait pas ça un traître
[Musique]
et un humain et une gueule gym départ en
fait je voulais faire une parodie de
cette tournée là parce que ça
m'intéressait je trouve ça amusant des
prêtres deviennent des sortes de
rockstar c'est tellement aux antipodes
les deux la religion pour moi c'est
juste un prétexte pour que les trois
bras cassés se rencontrent et finalement
la seule religion qui vont avoir si tu
allais faire marcher ensemble c'est la
musique mais loin d'en faire une satire
religieuse fabrice éboué a voulu que
coexister soit avant tout une critique
de la société d'aujourd'hui
c'était plus parler d'un d'un groupe
fabrique et pour un succès pour parler
de ce que ce soit l'humour où la musique
aujourd'hui on appartient tous à des
grands groupes qui font aussi bien
justement de la charcuterie que de la
lingerie que de la musique oui du
comique le 24 septembre dernier la
tournée de promotion a fait un arrêt à
saint quentin en yvelines pour plutôt
une bonne approche
en fait forcément de points de vue qui
sont différents mais avec toujours une
certaine légèreté et c'est vrai que
c'est assez bluffant de se dire que des
fois faut pas grand chose pour vivre
ensemble tu es assez souvent au cinéma
et ça faisait longtemps que j'avais
paris comme ça un film et je trouvais
que le thème était intéressant les
messages sont intéressants et c'est vrai
que c'est une histoire plutôt d'hommes
d'hommes qui se rencontrent avec une
très belle très belle histoire et les
sentiments la fin les aventures du
groupe co existent et sont à découvrir
en salles le 11 octobre groupe existait
quelque chose qui voulait à la
communauté juive moi c'est rabbi jacob
du sport et du football samedi dernier
les équipes réserve de caen et auxerre
s'affrontaient pour un match amical au
stade guy-boniface d'elancourt elles
évoluent toutes les deux en nationale 3
l'occasion de voir notamment à l'oeuvre
l'ancien élan courtois françois-xavier
fou mouhtam ouzou aujourd'hui joueur
professionnel chez les bourguignons
reportage de patrick jacques de dixmude
et mitchell et demi d'euros match de
gala à elancourt le club local a
accueilli ce samedi 24 septembre au
stade guy-boniface les réserves d'eau
serré de caen deux équipes qui évoluent
en nationale 3 l'équivalent de la
cinquième division
un match amical organisé dans le cadre
d'un partenariat avec les bourguignons
sa part d'un partenaire qui existe
depuis trois ans et demi bien maintenant
le mois février 2014
donc voilà c'est un apport en support
technique en plus pour retourner aussi
éducateur et pour nos joueurs c'est
important aussi car voilà de temps en
temps et détection qui s'organise chez
nous donc c'est des possibilités en plus
pour nous pour nos joueurs
certains joueurs du club ont pu profiter
de ces détections pour rejoindre les
professionnels c'est le cas de françois
xavier fou mouhtam ouzou 22 ans
aujourd'hui joueur de l'aja pour le voir
en action sur le terrain de ses débuts
des centaines de supporters ont fait le
déplacement
en fait c'est un petit jeune qui a
commencé dans le football avec mon
frangin mon petit frère
et voilà depuis on le suit et puis on
apprécier ce qui fait quoi
c'est époustouflant on a la chance
d'aller voir le match
auxerre est franchement avoir suivi sa
carrière et pouvoir le voir du haut des
gradins franchement avec les jeunes il
joue avec mon fils tout ça devrait
m'aider à la même équipe donc je le
suivais sur ce match donc pour ces
bornes
ça fait plaisir le match s'est terminé
sur un score de parité un but partout
entre les cannes et les auxerrois
d'autres rencontres amicales ecocert
pourraient être organisées dans les
prochains mois
sport toujours pour finir direction le
golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un an de la
ryder cup
le parcours accueille des légendes du
golf le pari seul agent championship une
étape française de l'european senior
tour organisé de vendredi à dimanche
vous le voyez sur ces images le pro-am
une session d'entraînement vient de se
terminer
c'était programmé pendant deux jours
prouve pour préparer les joueurs et les
puristes pourront voir en action 54
ancien professionnel comme le fantasque
américain john delli c'est la fin de ce
set 8 journal reportages et replay à
retrouver sur notre site internet et
notre application mobile atv 78 très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]